messieurs bonsoir bienvenue à 24,67
émission commence par une très belle
très bonne nouvelle c'est un nouveau
triomphe pour le réalisateur québécois
xavier dolan il remporte le prix du
meilleur film étranger à la cérémonie
des césars en france avait juste
d'arriver
il bat de grosses pointures comme ben
wood qui est justement l'un des favoris
pour les oscars ce dimanche
quelle émotion les beats quelle fierté
aussi
et quelle est la signification de ce
prix pour lui quand même qu'il y avait
eu le prix du jury à cannes je jouais au
téléphone ou par skype je ne sais trop
parce qu'à et xavier dolan bonsoir
d'habiller le soir alors par skype est
ce qu'on peut savoir vous êtes chez moi
j'ai pas trop inquiet êtes vous dans
quelle émotion et vous ben cheyrou
évidemment c'est niaiseux mais je re je
me trouve
ouais déçu de ne pas avoir été vous-même
à la cérémonie mais je pouvais pas je
travaille et je savais déjà les
obligations ici mais un mj grain de la
peau du que c'est allé tellement heureux
que ce soit elle qui l'est il avait qui
les prix qui l'a acceptée elle le mérite
tellement avec votre copine avec vous de
votre texte que vous aviez écrit pour la
cérémonie et sur mon ordinateur pourquoi
mais c'est parce que nous on n'a pas pu
la voir en direct
j'aurais peut-être aimé que ses rideaux
l'analyse une phrase ou deux de son
acceptation
ok ok j'ai souhaité tellement interactif
les médias la commune il parce que moi
je vais une exclusivité bon cher xavier
mais j'ai dit je remercie mes acteurs
d'abord j'ai dit je souhaite à tous de
travailler et des comédiens qui ont
autant d'imagination parce que
l'imagination et le caractère sont les
vertus les plus précieuses et des
acteurs elles sont aussi les plus rares
alors je remercie mes acteurs de leur
audace et de leur liberté
et puis après j'ai dit je vois comme la
france fut pour moi
dernières années au lieu d' acceptation
et de fraternité je voudrais donc ce
soir vous remerciera merci de ces
défraiements christian jeune festival de
cannes remercie la quinzaine des
réalisateurs a remercié les césars de
m'avoir depuis le tout début remarqué
accepté en plus abandonnés de votre
votre amitié vous m'avez donné la parole
vous avez du courage et de la confiance
il faut tellement confiance pour réussir
dans ce métier d'une confiance que
d'être jugée mal interprété et qui peut
s'écrouler souvent et rapidement vous
ajoutez pensez vous vouliez pas que je
lisais au complet donc en choisissant
momie vous dites aussi que les films
dits d'amour peuvent encore se démarquer
malgré le cinéma sombre et sérieux que
commande cette époque vous dire que
malgré les divergences le désaccord les
accents les cultures les couleurs sont
uniques
nos coeurs à travers la bat à l'unisson
merci d'avoir compris mon histoire merci
de m'accorder cette chance merci xavier
dolan de remarques de que d'entendre ces
mots lus par vous dit par vous senti par
vous après avoir au fond a dit à
quelques reprises que de faire un film
c'est une démarche difficile cet appel
cruel c'est c'est laborieux c'est
difficile mais c'est en même temps
qu'elle gratification pour vous
qu'est-ce que ce qu'est ce que ce prix
ce soir ajoute à votre détermination à
votre confiance que vous évoquez dans le
texte
justement ça ajoute énormément
ça veut dire souvent qu'on fait pas ce
thème l'homme pour les prix mais on le
fait par contre pour que pour être
compris pour que que les films soient
vus aimé et pris sa vie d'une communauté
de gens qui ont aimé le film qui vous
ont compris donc pour moi ça ça
participe du même c'est de récompense
donc ça m'encourage puis ça me donne du
sens me donne beaucoup de force parce
que parce qu'on sort on sont deux sentir
seul partant dans ce métier là et puis
c'est très dur je donne tout à ça c'est
ma seule passion c'est la seule chose
qui me qui même qu'ils ne transportent
vraiment dans la vie pis c'est juste ça
que je fais tout le temps
chacun dans ma vie donc donc ça me fait
ça fait plaisir au travail 70 c'est
extrêmement important en effet vous avez
dit de ce film j'ai peut-être le goût de
citer une entrevue fait en france ou six
mois 1000 documentaire d'une belle
maladie incurable maladie d'amour
maladie de la jeunesse qui n'aura
survécu doublé que le temps d'une
rémission pendant les très fertile 2h14
c'est votre film avez vous déjà dit
aussi le plus social vous avez touché
quelque chose d'universel
est-ce que ça fait partie des raisons
pour lesquelles le film a été si bien
accueillis en france je pense lui mais
aussi parce que je pense que dans un
film qu'on m'a faite vous savez avec
avec notre coeur qu'avec la socialité
puis ils défilent dans la vie qui sont
intelligents et des films qui sont
intrigants et des films qui sont
éducatif
il ya des films qui sont qui me donne
des palpitations des jeunes qui sont
horrifiant des fonctions d'euros puis il
ya des films qui sont touchants que je
sais pas exactement ce qu'on a fait avec
mon ami juste super sonic joly co je l'
ai vu je lis compris qu'on avait touché
les gens disent oh je pense que c'est un
type de cinéma qui je pense que les les
émotions le coeur l'âme l'homme d'un
film du moins est ce qu'on peut en
ressentir compte dans une salle dans le
noir
c'est parmi les expériences qui vont ou
même qui laisse une trace sur nous et
puis j'espère que que momie en a laissé
une sur sur les gens qui l'ont vu dans
la vie des gens qu'ils ont c'est
peut-être pour ça que les gens on entend
parler d'abord parce que c'est un film
qui fonctionne avec avec le coeur qui
pensent qu'ils pensent avec l'auteur
français avec affaire clavier je voulais
vous poser une question qu'il ya déjà
plusieurs mois de ça après avoir vu le
film j'ai vu quelques fois le film j'ai
perdu ma distance journalistique parce
que j'ai pleuré beaucoup il m'a beaucoup
ému le film est une des fois que j'ai vu
je les ai vus en compagnie d'une mère
dont le fils souffre comme votre
personnage est elle aussi pleuré puis
elle aussi disait si les gens savaient
que ça touche des dizaines de milliers
de familles de personnes ici on vivrait
pas sa seule dans notre isolement dans
notre indifférence
qu'est ce que ça vous fait je vous
transmets le témoignage de cette même
l'appel
autant le samedi du bien mais c'est pour
ça que c'est dommage de voir momie
comment un film sur les enfants rois où
les maires et responsables
on a vu certains chroniqueurs certaines
personnes dit oui mais aujourd'hui les
enfants sont tellement tout le temps
tainos ticket d'office de 2 et dj ou de
hyperactif qui ont aimé sur les piles de
dlh de william hérité dans tout seul
mais il faut pas nier non plus le fait
que la maladie mentale existe que des
enfants qui sont les personnes qui est
ni pour faire mal ou pour faire de mal
pour l'homme le des gens moins chanceux
que d'autres et il faut les écouter les
en tant pis si momie peut être une
occasion pour vous de se sentir avant
d'être entendu ou compris dans nulle
tant réussi six as pu leur procurer un
peu de solidarité
effectivement le sentiment que cette
mère avait vous avez vos clés les
surdiagnostic vous avez dit dans votre
tête je veux y revenir parce que le film
a rencontré son public en est pas finie
sans doute de le rencontrer vous avez
dit la france fut pour moi qu'on est
derniers donné à lieu d'acceptation et
de fraternité qu'est-ce qu'on peut aller
un peu plus loin derrière ça parce qu'à
cannes s'est pour l'heure tout
recommencer ou 1 avant d'aller à la
cazine les attentes étaient personnes
les jantes on me disait retourne à
l'école de pensée qu'il faut aller dans
les festivals arrêtent de rêver en
couleurs descend sur terre descend sur
terre qui j'avais la naïveté de croire
que oui c'était possible qu'on aille à
cannes on est allé puis tout a commencé
là pour moi en fait
donc ce que je dis c'est que par le
destin comme ça il se trouve que ce soit
la france mais donné ma première chance
mais depuis m'ont jamais oublié les
césar ont nui film à chaque année ils
étaient pas obligés où il était pas un
c'est quand même j'ai tué ma mère à côté
des films auprès desquels il était nommé
je fais un film qui rougit un but la
campagne c'est de dissiper un premier
film depuis mais ils ont été comme ça
toujours curieux de me demandant de me
considérer de m'accepter puis c'est dur
de rentrer dans les rangs c'est dur de
2,2 sentir chez soi quelques pensées
c'est dur de les gens sont méfiants
envers les nouveaux venus les nouvelles
fois les gens qui sont un peu différents
on les critique au lait donc pour moi en
france il ya toujours eu ça toujours été
un territoire depuis le tout début qui
était extrêmement ouvert en effet et je
dois en suis très reconnaissant j'ai
trouvé donc il était fraternel qu'ils
étaient juste amicaux et fraternelle
l'espace est ce que je soulignais avec
ce 3 qu'est ce qui a été dit ou écrit de
plus juste de plus beaux sont momie en
plus d'en savoir le premier sou
tellement belles choses qui ont été
écrites il ya un gros comme tâche pas en
tout cas pas mal depuis toujours en fait
c'est ici c'est aux autres magazines
jeudi film est un film sur l'affairé
la férocité la violence parfois de 2 de
l'amour d'une mère qui commence que
c'est donc je sais ce que c'est ce que
le plus beau est peut-être des choses
qui sont mieux tourner et des choses qui
sont plus politiques quelques cellules
mais il me semble que cela ait été été
assez juste mais l'amour maternel
inconditionnel n'a pas de limite et je
pense que je vais vous laisser filer
xavier si vous me promettez de venir en
studio ce moment je sais que j'avais une
classe de maître jeudi prochain à 19h30
je sais que tout était complet moi je
suis un nom je peux pas y aller jusqu'en
plein de gens qui veulent y allez allez
vous changer de sallèles et bouchra les
voix ferme supplémentaires je ne sais
pas s'il ya eu de décider ouais elle
volontaire comment la première et en
terminale et si vous aviez évoqué notre
première entrevue ensemble j'en ignorais
des boues non mais on s'expliquera
xavier je pense que dans tous nos
téléspectateurs
on voulait votre chapeau en vous
félicitant vous embrasse et je suis sûr
que cette mère avec qui j'ai vu le film
vous embrasserait très fort également et
je la salue ce soir ok merci beaucoup
vous aviez on vous laisse filer vous
êtes très en demande
merci merci xavier au revoir